the Greek gods while not worshiped by
many anymore the Greek gods are still in
our lives they are depicted in the
compendium of Western art and literature
they indirectly give us the names of our
planets days of the week and names of
the months they show up in the names of
products in our movies and in our books
you'll often hear that the ancient
Greeks had 12 main Gods and that's true
yet there were dozens if not hundreds of
Greek gods demigods and Spirits within
their Pantheon I obviously won't go over
all of them here but I believe there are
20 gods that everyone should know
the ancient Greeks had no Bible or
equivalent there was no canonical
version of their mythology I'll be using
a modified version of hessia's theogony
but if I mention a God or myth
associated with said God don't be
surprised if it's different from the
version you know
[Music]
in the beginning there was chaos a
swirling void of nothingness and
orderlessness from this chaos sprung
Gaia the Earth she was the mother of all
creation every God and every monster can
be traced back to her she bore a number
of primordial Gods but the most
important was Uranus Uranus was the sky
together Uranus and Gaia produced many
creatures and deities and yeah you'll
have to get used to some strange
incestuous relationships in this story
but don't worry they're Gods Not people
now aranis was a pretty awful father he
hated his children and locked them away
in the bowels of the Earth this enraged
Gaia and so she gave a sickle to one of
her sons Chronos Kronos then defeated
and castrated his father becoming the
new ruler of the Gods
this generation of gods were called the
Titans
as I said Cronus was the king of the
Titans and God of Agriculture the
Harvest and time Kronos married his
sister Reya she was also an agricultural
goddess and was later worshiped as the
mother of the Gods Kronos and Reya ruled
over the Golden Age of Greek mythology
but while times may have been golden for
some they weren't so good for cronus's
children
you see when Uranus was defeated by
Kronos he gave a prophecy that Kronos
would befall the same fate as him
as punishment for betraying his father
Kronos would be overthrown by one of his
own children
Kronos who was terrified of this ate his
first five children when they were born
Reya who wasn't a fan of seeing her
children devoured by her husband hatched
a plan she hid away her sixth born son
and gave Kronos a stone swaddled in
cloth instead Kronos who we can only
guess wasn't too observant swallowed the
stone and thought nothing else of it
Raya then took her son named Zeus to be
raised by nymphs when he grew up he
snuck his father a poison that made him
throw up his other children this started
the titanomaki a war between the
Olympians led by Zeus and the Titans led
by Kronos
it lasted 10 years and in the end the
Olympians won Zeus then imprisoned the
Titans in Tartarus the deepest pit of
the underworld
so let's meet these new rulers of the
universe
first we have Zeus though he was last
born he was the strongest of his
siblings and took over his father's
Throne as king of the Gods
he was Lord of the sky and God of
Thunder Destiny and kingship his symbol
was his Thunderbolt made by the mighty
cyclopsis he was also famously
promiscuous having dozens upon dozens of
children both God and Mortal with dozens
of women his wife was Hera she was the
queen of the gods and goddess of
motherhood marriage and the Stars she
was famously unhappy with Zeus's
infidelity often cursing or killing
zuzu's Mistresses and children
Poseidon was given Dominion of the sea
and was King and God of it one of his
titles was the earth Shaker as he was
the cause of earthquakes and tsunamis he
was also God of horses for some reason
Demeter was the goddess of the Harvest
Grain and of Agriculture she was most
well known for the story of her daughter
but we'll get to that later
next we have Hestia she is often
forgotten when talking about the gods of
ancient Greece so much so that people
fail to include her in the 12 Olympians
but she was one she was the goddess of
Hearth and Home and tender of the fire
of Olympus
last of the children of Kronos Andrea
was Hades
he was the god of the dead and King of
the underworld but he wasn't actually
included in the 12 Olympians as his
dwelling was in the Land of the Dead not
Mount Olympus
so those are the first six or five
Olympians
before we move on to the second
generation we have another goddess to
cover
Aphrodite was the goddess of love and
beauty and she may have been the oldest
Olympian of them all
when crotos castrated his father aranis
his hmm let's say privates were hurled
into the sea from this event came the
Sea Foam and through some Godly magic
Aphrodite was born
so there's our first generation of
Olympians the next six are all Children
of Zeus
the first were the twins Artemis and
Apollo they were the Children of Zeus
and the titanus lito Artemis was the
goddess of Untamed nature the hunt and
wild animals she was a maiden goddess
and was said to have an aversion to men
other than her brother she was also a
moon goddess though not the only one in
Greek mythology
her twin Apollo was the god of archery
poetry art and prophecy the famed Oracle
of Delphi was of The High Priestess of
the Temple of Apollo this temple in
Delphi was thought to be the center of
the world to the ancient Greeks next to
Zeus Apollo was probably the most
important god of the Greek pantheon as
with his sister Apollo was a sun god
though again not the only one in Greek
myth next we have the goddess Athena her
birth story is a weird one one day Zeus
woke up with up monster headache it grew
so bad that he asked one of the other
gods to cleave open his skull with an ax
the god did so and the goddess Athena
sprang from Zeus's head fully grown and
fully armored
Athena was the goddess of wisdom of
strategy and of BattleCraft
she is the last of our Maiden goddesses
joining Hestia and Artemis the city of
Athens was named after her and she was
its Patron deity and protector
along with her dominion over Warcraft
she was also a goddess of domestic
crafts like weaving
so Zeus's wife Hera was not pleased that
Zeus had a child without her help so she
decided to have a child without his
through some Godly magic she did just
that and boar Hephaestus
unfortunately Hephaestus was born lame
meaning disabled it's suggested by his
epithet kylo podion that he was born
with a club foot but it's a little
unclear whatever his handicap was it was
enough for Hera to cast her infant son
out of Olympus um
luckily he was found by fetus the C
nymph and was raised in her abode
there among the nymphs they taught him
the art of metalwork and smithing he
proved to be good at this in fact he
proved to be the greatest metal worker
anybody had ever seen
as revenge on his mother he presented
Hera a beautiful Golden Throne when he
was invited back to Olympus he Enchanted
the throne to trap Hera when she sat on
it Zeus begged Hephaestus to free her
which he promised to do if he was given
Aphrodite's hand in marriage Zeus agreed
much to Aphrodite's frustration and hair
was freed Hephaestus was the blacksmith
of the Gods and the god of metalwork and
Fire
next we have Ares the god of war he was
funnily enough the only of the 12
Olympians born of Zeus and his wife Hera
Ares was the god of Bloodshed and
violence but also of courage and
discipline he famously had an adulterous
affair with Aphrodite the Goddess of
love
and lastly of the Olympians is Hermes he
was son of Zeus and Maya he was the
messenger and Herald of the Gods as well
as the god of Travelers merchants and
thieves
he was a trickster God as well as a
bringer of knowledge when he was a child
he stole Apollo's sacred cattle as a
prank when Zeus found this out he was
amused by hermes's gall
after Hermes returned Apollo's cattle on
Zeus's orders as well as showed Apollo
his liar which he had invented all was
forgiven and he became one of the 12
Olympians
and those are the 12 Olympians but we're
not done yet there are a few minor gods
that are still very important to know
first we have Persephone she was the
daughter of Zeus and Demeter and her
story was one of the most important
myths in Greek religion you see Hades
god of the underworld fell in love with
her he went to his brother Zeus and
asked for her hand in marriage Zeus
agreed while conveniently forgetting to
tell either Persephone or her mother
damage her so one day when Persephone
was chilling with some nymphs a crack
appeared in the earth out from it came
Hades who kidnapped Persephone and took
her to the underworld her mother Demeter
was so distraught that all of the
vegetation on earth started to die
Zeus realizing that the only way to calm
Demeter's wrath was to get her daughter
back sent Hermes to fetch her
but Persephone had eaten a pomegranate
from the underworld in this tied her to
the place so she was forced to live in
the Underworld with her husband for a
third of the Year this story acted as an
explanation for the seasons Persephone
was in the Underworld during winter and
when she was on Olympus it was spring
next we have Dionysus Dionysus was born
of Zeus and simile the princess of
Thebes Yep this is the first character
we've come across who had a mortal
mother that said semley was herself a
demigod as she was the daughter of the
Goddess harmonia when Dionysus was
conceived the ever jealous in spiteful
Hera killed simile Zeus then took The
Unborn Dionysus and sewed him into his
thigh Dionysus was then born from Zeus's
thigh because of this Dionysus was often
called twice born
he was the god of wine festivity and
Madness
since he was technically part human
though Immortal he acted as a bridge
between the immortal world and the
Divine this made him one of the most
popular Greek gods
lastly Eros better known today by his
Roman name Cupid was the son of
Aphrodite and ares he was like his
mother a god of love and desire
interestingly in hessian's theogony and
in other early accounts Eros is
presented as a primordial god of the
same generation as Gaia and aranas but
in later Hellenistic times as well as in
Rome he was always thought to be the
child of Aphrodite and ares he's of
course famous for his bow and arrow that
he would use to make people and even
other gods fall in love so those are the
20 Greek gods I think everyone should
know let me know in the comments any
favor gods of yours I missed I think I
will do a follow-up video because there
are so many interesting gods and
goddesses from ancient Greece to cover
if you want to support the Channel
please consider donating to my patreon
or just like And subscribe
bye